[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment il est bienvenu dans on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge
zot lé bien moins mais mieux alors
aujourd'hui on est au mac dans les hauts
de saint louis
c'est magnifique je suis bien content on
est avec gym ou et clémentine et ils ont
un élevage de poulets bio oui marmaille
pour les bio ça ils mangent rien vous a
fait à biot pas d'actions tesla est bon
donc mon idée je viens avec moi allons
voir of hell et venez venez revivre
[Musique]
point
hier
[Musique]
oh
bonjour clémentine comment il est là où
même ballet justement qui pâtit pas bah
déjà mais aussi d'accueil à nos bas avec
plaisir dans notés firme en agriculture
biologique tout c est chiant but ou pas
c'est pas tout est certifiée bio images
on dira donc ça nous les et signer dans
les autres ça lui ben mon mari les
origines a dit simhon ministre de deux
filles de saint paul et voilà les dans
les eaux certain paul le ballon est dans
les eaux on appelle ça l'amour mes
enfants ils feraient un le soir vie en
hiver on fait mention donc t elle à ses
outils du quart aux fanatiques à
rouffach et dirty diana au le milieu des
cars aux belles années que tout ne l'a
fait le shoot calomnie la basilique à
peine un petit peu la mode lent comme
arena puis de koro ni les fous de long
thành elle s'aiguise brésil de l'inde et
variétés brouillard goyave comme diane
kruger est à prendre dans la blanche
aussi maintenant le coronel est juste
derrière
après maintenant les avenants dans le
car qui les petits samba pays baltes et
exploitation quoi
[Musique]
alors nous voilà arrivés diamant combien
pour un intérêt pour les deux coques
pour les communes angers de l'a320 320
dans les deux côtés de chaque de l'a320
320 la même superficie que me suppose
des calculé par rapport au nombre il
vous plait présentes dans le bâtiment
n'avait m² effet 16 par mètre carré
donc nous retournons à 3 120 poulets
dans le vague de petits bâtiments
c'est quoi un poulet bio cuit il fait
les caractéristiques des poulets bio
c'est quoi obliger en guillemets de
faire pour ben par un bon poulet bio
déjà l'alimentation les bio et la
majeure partie des autres vissé sur le
parcours voilà zahlé dur donc dès qu'ils
commencent qu'à les plumes bien nommé
sur le parcours et la 12e et nous a fait
des apports aussi on aime parce que le
parquet s'invite aussi donc normal les
troncs de bananes ont mené différents de
légumes que les déchets les fidèles
canada sur l'exploitation les salades
les choux n'ont même pas mal de
désert vous autres à l'intérieur en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que tout ce qui
est aliments industriels c'est non c'est
non
toute l'alimentation les certifiés bios
à 0
la poigne prophylaxie pizza ou donna aux
antibiotiques médicament n'a pas du tout
ça lance moment si moche que ça va être
le maillon créé songé conflits et des
bananes sur ce dossier mme sa banane
ananas banane la couper en dés là on va
dire mendonça mannheim ansa à willems
aissati marc lajouanique comme ça ils
donnent là la chair les particuliers
[Rires]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
donc là où j'ai passé les poules et les
mots pour passer à la tuerie combien de
mois n'a presque 120 je dois dire où est
cette fille en bio font de prendre tout
ça un jour alors quid haut et après ben
je cherche de la sorte on vit les champs
directement jusqu'à l'abattage et la
majeure partie les lieux voilà voilà
parce que en plus non seulement on en a
la nourriture le poulet on en a le fait
que c'est mon choix d'aliments
industriels mais aussi le fait que wyeth
en poussins ii un joueur de national à
suis comme les jeunes apprennent des
apports de rien à part à part la couette
et là à part l'accident avait eu des
causes analyser tout ce qu'il faut pour
développer ces temps fait qu'on bosse
house il doit faire le plus attention
vraiment une fois qu'on aime à tous et
est là ben si à tout suivre cette
évolution parce que comme moi et s'ils
commencent bien la grippe a mais ne peut
se faire qu'à piscine le même plaisir
naturel le dindon qui prévienne tout ça
contre les maladies mais après c'est pas
vraiment malade non ça n'a tout ce qu'il
en a dans le sol on n'a pas suffi à son
développement
citons coque malade tu prends des fleurs
de capuche et une psychologue d'accord
quand on copie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un beau quoique c'est quoi alors aoyama
cette définition à bangkok bangkok pour
moi c'est être pas grave il est bien
musclé et conserva bataille à la marmite
là bas c'est un athlète noir parce qu'il
est tellement en forme tellement joli
haut gradé belle aussi bon et
aboutissants le coryphée rokocoko et
comment le coquillard inscrits au wat
non
[Musique]
terra nova avait parlement d'un projet
de l'été dessus c'était la bh une tuerie
pour être aux normes mais bien d'accord
baal enfin de voir ça
[Musique]
et affinités
ici la mer les sites créés comme
[Musique]
comme à goutte la rosée
poser si la brutale en démon s'il nous
arrive dans l'acide sulfurique est déjà
bien avancé et on a lu tu es t à la
jimmy enchanté ben alors on voit un
petit peu comment ça se passe à
l'intérieur en travaux mais mais elle
est déjà bien le lieu du crime prochaine
à sa seule occasion des rations pour
elle a fait la boucle bouclée quoi elle
va asturies mais suppose que les pas
donné tout ce matos la balle et quelques
duels on peut dire que ben on est
quasiment on sent à l'aise tout est fait
à la main et diamants c'est quoi ça ces
trucs-là l'aller les rares mais voit pas
ça beaucoup un tir bas c'est le
troisième incident en ligne
d'accord une éolienne et bien cette
année offre une formation éoliennes sur
téva et du coup que l'éolienne tout
l'été fait surface d'accord c'est que du
de soudure du monde tout départ le
bobinage tout le reste tout est fait à
la main ici pour l'équipe de formation
que
les gens qui étaient présents des deux
formes le là pour le coup on energy lui
suffit à couvrir quoi pourrait on aller
à gidy suffit à couvrir toute notre
demande en énergie au niveau la tuerie
même mieux même mieux parce que collet
bami fait de la soudure me fait tout
avec donc c'est qu il est pas là c'est
du vieux du début jusqu'à la fin et en
complément avec les panneaux solaire à
l'éolien ou le relais quand même rappaz
le vent + panneaux solaires voilà le
monde a tendance à dire que les
audiences et de bruit et entend pourtant
quelque chose du tout john bien et a dit
pas plus pour que le vent n'ont fait
banal à l e puis c'est qu'on voit pas
vraiment devant fait la joie de l'équipe
pas jack c'est un temps devant témoins
me dis juste bravo vous y voir une étude
à terre c'est une chanson de chansons de
trenet
[Musique]
il pense que si on a déjà un joueur est
intéressé par ce système
contactez nous voilà est de mettre en
relation avec les cassettes qui face à
des gens comme super ça bravo les gens
beaux arts
[Musique]
alors on va les curieux mais trop
cueillez grammont d'examen alexandre
trop curieux défauts et qualités colline
mais la logique semaine et veut
connaître si je les connais tu dis moi
comment ce2 les arrivées à dire que mme
dati ça met sur une exploitation et sa
femme états et à l'agriculture bio et à
l'élevage bio couvert en gros c'est que
douala nana deux enfants dont une
la dernière est autiste est bon c'est
vrai il faut pas se leurrer on nous dit
pas clairement mais c'est logique que
pour moi c'est logique que ces
alimentations et qui fait que tout ce
qui est problème neurologique de santé à
l'eau aujourd'hui chez jean pour moi
c'est l'alimentation on sait que donc on
s'est promis de nous et nos enfants
donc les produits avec de vrais pros
naturels bio et samedi et surtout c'est
que nous on fait du bio mais on
n'utilise aucun pesticide bio aucun
engrais bio toutes les assurances a
confirmé dans de l'exploitation c'est
qu'on n'utilise que du fumier raf
étonnons nous inviter produits-là
dernier ban a dit ben quoi pas nous fait
pour les autres si mais c'est la mienne
commence planking les uns sur les autres
là en fait vraiment salaces et les
autres l'aise a commencé et puis j'ai
rendu compte que c'est the drug c'est
aussi de faire mon genou ah oui voilà
donc ce vol très important parce que
parce que justement moment donné faut
nommer notre confiance aussi dans une
main exo tyson main et faire en sorte
que ben voila quoi nous nourrir nous
mieux en tout cas parce qu'il faut se
mesurer au mieux et avec des produits
bio c'est juste terrible et en plus un
bios on va dire un vieux du début
jusqu'à la fin en fait c'est ça que
nécessaire mais timidement érable décret
on a fait pour nous faire une fan a fait
peloter y en a qu'on ait goûté la tête
de mots dessus mais pas nintendo dans le
sang le sol par google earth est de mode
sur dix suit 107 pour la santé une sorte
de normes à une culture petits-enfants
que plutôt réalité de quelque chose de
vraiment pas trop bien les passes
signifie pas rien j'ai rien à rajouter
voilà mabri tarde de retrouver les
novices à la bonne route à sa merci
et voilà l'émission se termine et vous
mettez à la cour achète donc on s'est
arrêté au lieu-dit pépinière toujours
aux marques un petit endroit super on
peut pique-niquer fait son petit paris 2
comme bio et je sens bien là donc j'ai
pu aller trappe et moi je vous dis tout
simplement aurevoir
je reviendrai je te promets petit
bonhomme et petite madame je reviendrai
à la prochaine et sincèrement on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge
forcément qu'on mérite bien là
[Musique]